doesn't exactly apply to our category
but I certainly think she has deserved
it because she was the first lady of
comics Joan Lee passed away this week
she was the wife of comics legend Stan
Lee and she was his bride for 69 years
they were together I just interviewed
them on in January there's a company
called Legion em that wanted to do a
legacy interview with Stan at his house
in VR format so essentially they shot
you know if you've ever heard the terms
thrown around 2k 4k right those are kind
of formats that are common right now cuz
that's what you can screen things in as
well they had cameras that were shooting
at 12 K so they didn't have an ability
to watch it back I was like let's watch
it like we don't have a monitor that can
play it yet so I'm like boy I hope it
[ __ ] turned out and [ __ ] one liver
net so while we were doing the piece
like it's cool it's VR piece eventually
when it's done so you'll be in the room
with us while we sit there and talk and
I just go over his entire life in his
career so we did it at Stan's house and
so they brought Joanie up as well and
you know Joanie was 93 years old Stan's
94 so Joanie came up to be interviewed
and you know it's top floor Stan's
houses all these [ __ ] marvel mementos
sitting around and stuff and Joanie sat
down for what had to be the billionth
interview about like so your husband huh
and you know she's so wonderful and and
she's a British woman so she has this
wonderful accent and you know she's
telling the same story she's been forced
to tell as the wife of the ambassador of
comics for the last 50 years and stuff
so in the middle of asking her to tell
the story yet again which we'd heard
Stan just tell but the very famous story
about Stan wanted to quit Marvel he was
like I'm done with this and that there
were no superheroes yet and stuff they
were doing a funny animal comic
they were doing westerns nurse comics
romance caption and funnies where you
take a photo of somebody real and then
put a funny word balloon on it but Stan
Watts right Stan wines are at the Great
American Novel and he felt that the
comic books were like he wasn't getting
to do what he wanted to do in the books
and he didn't think it was worth his
time he wanted to move on pitch the
dream of being a writer so his white
young wife at that point Joanie who he
had met when she he went to a party and
knocked on a door and she was just on
her way out to get air and she opens the
door and Stanley ever the writer and you
got to remember this is the man who's
given us our modern mythology the words
out of his mouth are so smooth he goes
oh my god you're so beautiful I've been
drawing you my whole life hmm
now I'd [ __ ] Stanley with a line like
that yeah you know and the way Stan
tells the story they were together from
that point forward and they were each
other's best friends and stuff so
there's Joanie
telling the story yet again of you know
Stan wanted to quit I'm not gonna try to
do a beautiful voice that can't even do
it but she says Stan wanted to quit and
I said to him just look if you're
quitting anyway just write what you want
like just one the way you were right one
the way you want to do it [ __ ] I'm chins
I'd [ __ ] him but like you know do your
thing and he's like okay and he went in
and he wrote that and it was fantastic
for number one which is the birth of the
Marvel Universe many consider it to be
the modern Marvel Universe and that's
that begins a long run of [ __ ]
creating some of the most well known
characters that pop culture has ever
seen used to be pop culture they're so
dominant now it is the culture so one
could make the argument that if his best
friend in the world Joan doesn't say
give it a shot right one for you we
never get the Marvel Universe it doesn't
happen and stuff like it all stops with
[ __ ] Batman and Superman so she was a
powerful powerful woman she's telling
that story yet again dutifully as the
woman who sat by him and you know
listened to him talk about comics
forever and talk about spider-man and
all who would beat who and stuff
his absolute Pied Piper for books has
been ever since we were kids so in the
middle of it responding to that question
and telling that story yet again she
stops and she just gets very emotional
eyes glass up and she goes like this and
I was like a year Ione and she goes it's
always spider-man spider-man spider-man
they don't know the writer that this man
truly is poems every day for the last 50
years or more and she started quoting
poetry that Stan wrote well she's in my
line of sight and she's on camera stands
off-camera but right behind her
Joanie's getting like crying talking
about her her beautiful best friend man
she spent her entire [ __ ] life with
and how even though we all love him for
the [ __ ] we love him for there's we
never scratch the surface
yeah the guy is a truly amazing gifted
writer and there's Stan just off camera
man and rolling a tear these two we
loved each other dude in a way that like
you know sometimes you're married I'm
married sometimes you're like oh my god
we'll get how many more years of this
are we done yet
those two were never done with one
another they were each other's best
friends like he had to be done with
things at like five six o'clock so we'd
go home have dinner with Joanie and they
could take a nap and stuff like and
where he was he was every event I always
saw him at she was by his side she was
the inspiration for a character in the
books and in the cartoons mostly called
Madame web she looked like her as well
but yeah it was heartbreaking to to read
I mean she was 93 he's 94 but still they
were so vibrant dude again just in
January
what are you doing 94 after after 70
years of marriage without your best
friend and partner I just I feel for him
that the absence is going to have
significant so this week if you're here
in this you know jump on social media
Twitter Instagram throw him love yeah a
lot of love right now he needs to be
reminded because imagine your best
friend of seven decades is suddenly gone
you want maybe maybe it's good the rest
of us reminded Mountain portney as to
all of us there's a shot of the two of
them together
we have that picture I just think it's
so beautiful it's like there they are
it's just everywhere they went together
constantly his arm was around her he was
kissing her he was holding her hand he
was touching her he loved him like he
absolutely loved her but she loved him
yeah it was clear in the interview but
it was always clear and their lives
together you walk around I've been lucky
enough to be in their home you walk
around and it's not like what you would
think where every [ __ ] square inch is
marvel but you see their lifetime
together and she appointed that house
[ __ ] beautifully it's like a museum
and there's a there there's a Charles
I'm I don't even know if I'm supposed to
share this Charles Schulz the peanuts
creator only did two paintings in his
entire life
and one of them hangs in Stanley's house
oh wow I remember Joanie talk pointing
out she's like you know who did this I
was like no but it's gorgeous it's a
portrait of Stan and she goes Charles
Schulz and I was like Charlie Brown she
goes Snoopy
she's a wonderful wonderful woman
she'll be deeply missed by anyone who
ever met her but it should of course be
most deeply missed by Stan yeah so I
wanted to give her a little a little
dude tonight yeah for her
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh